[Music]
maybe it's time Olivia
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe it's time Olivia always takes luck
to change main Hill it takes a lot to
try
[Music]
you know man in the old days I always
knew like you were gonna do something
that you'd be alright it's the first
time I'm worried about you can I ask you
a personal question okay tell me
something good do you write songs or
anything
I don't sing my own songs why I just
don't feel comfortable why won't you
feel comfortable almost every single
person has told me they liked the way I
sounded but that they didn't like the
way I look I think you're beautiful
[Music]
Hey what I just want to take another
look at you and all the good times I
find myself
well change isn't gonna get become sing
that song what I love to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Eddie Brock I'm the reporter now I
always seem to find myself questioning
something the government may not be
looking at I found something really bad
and I have been taken
look around in the world who do you see
a planet on the brink of collapse human
games are disposable McMahon and
symbiotes combined this is a new race
your species a higher life-form
what do you want me
[Applause]
we cannot just hurt people
my lady
we have a deal so many time
to that power it's not completely awful
you have no idea how much you're scaring
me right now a walk away
and you just might survive guys you do
not want to do this trust me
oops
we'll always come at a cost
[Music]
you will be this office will be rolling
down the street
[Music]
oh I have a parasite yeah name is Chan
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
first time of the old Royale you have
the option to stay in either California
or Nevada I always want to stay in
honeymoon suite
even though I'm not currently on my
honeymoon I got a job singing arena
tomorrow don't pay nothing but a thing
in this thing this is not a place for a
priest father you shouldn't be here
it's a little too quiet in there it
gives me the willies
[Music]
just to pick to be true sir we have a
problem
you watch me I only want to they tell me
to watch these legs
management do you think you could just
take this mind I wouldn't come a hug no
I figured you would and I mean he lost
father can I confess something to you
I'm not really a priest
it's a game it all starts with a simple
choice would you mind opening the door
which cider you want right wrong God or
no God red or black
horrible joke everybody [ __ ] happened to
get the whiskey
[Music]
these are extraordinary times and we
face an extraordinary challenge the
dramatic achievements in space which
occurred in recent weeks should have
made play to us all the impact of this
adventure on the minds of men everywhere
now it is time to take longer strides
time for a great new American Enterprise
time for this nation to take a clearly
leading role in space achievement which
in many ways may hold the key to our
future on earth I believe that this
nation should commit itself to achieving
the goal of landing a man on the moon
and returning him safely to the earth
[Music]
we set sail on this gem sea because
there is new knowledge to be gained
help decide whether this new ocean will
be a sea of peace or a new terrifying
theater of war
but why some say the moon
I climb the highest mountain
we choose to go to the moon in this
the other things not because they are
easy but because they are hard
[Music]
[Music]
it's turning old Halloween around here
[Music]
I don't think this place is giving out
candy
[Music]
[Music]
haunted Halloween
[Music]
did you miss me
you discovered a walking talking dummy
and you didn't tell me okay well he
seemed like a really nice guy at the
start
[Music]
they're moving so tiny and cubic may
possibly do
[Music]
funny they just come e bears
please go to do they're all spooky I'm
gonna pick that one over I'll treat
forty years ago on Halloween night
Michael Myers murdered three people
after that horrific night he was sent
back to the institution in captivity
I have prayed her every night that he
would escape labelled did you do that
for
so I can kill him the bus crashed
Michael Myers escaped he returned to
having filled his home I need to protect
my family you have no security system
Karen you need help evil is really
there's the reason we're supposed to be
afraid of the sight I've been preparing
for this for a long time it is not safe
to be on the street tonight he's here he
is a killer but he will be killed
tonight
happy Halloween Michael
[Music]
I'm out here you like to say everybody
knows everything what if the truth was
nobody knows anything I got a feeling
today yesterday today's the day I can
feel it this time I can feel him
good to see you John it took so long to
find you what do you say say I'm not
gone John anymore it's funny huh why
would you want to find me my husband has
never seen your face you were right
about him
are you siding with him what's this this
is a scratch it'll scratch huh I want
you to take him out on your boat and
drop him in the ocean for the Sharks
they say she came all the way to see you
yes she's about temptation it's right
and wrong in Plymouth everybody knows
everything I've been kind of a big day
tomorrow I know all about your big day
it's like everybody knows something I
know
how you explain that deal will you have
yourself a good day now and do what's
right okay deliver me from temptation
are you going to take them out they're
not right in your mind
my wife says you're being a little
difficult
there's something wrong like this is all
about
sometimes we do bad things for good
reasons this is the most aggressive
military buildup in Russian history
that's all six feet you want a
hunter-killer we've been ordered across
waters that no American sub has ever
crossed before take us along the ocean
floor
we've been keeping tabs on Russian
president his defense minister it's a
coup
what if we could free president Sakaki
we rescue the Russian president we're
going in with four of our boys run
training simulations for this one if we
don't pull this off it's gonna be World
War three
that's a warship
battle stations get ready
and ready ready fire
at the beginning she gave me things
perfect balance perfect sleep she wants
to get inside of me I can feel her she
can see me
[Music]
when you dance the dance of another you
make yourself in the image of its
creator I feel like I'm not even here
you dumped like some kind of the way she
transmitted some work you have to decide
what is it you want to be for this
company there's more in that building
than what you can see dr. dangerous
people three mothers play God the tavern
mother Tenenbaum
mother mom
Billy all darkness inside you making
some kind of deal with them
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
here
the one that's coming I'm not sure I've
ever met a man quite like you you
haven't a problem good virtual reality
it's completely immersive as some people
lose track their surroundings
that's not gonna happen I just ask what
is wrong with you or did you not burn
the Cote du Coq restaurant to the ground
mmm
a did you fire a missile at Apple at all
a French cyclist well before
commandeering an open-top bus and
tossing the tall guy off the top deck
you